bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week end
l'émission consacrée vous le savez à vos
idées de sorties pour le week end au
programme de la culture avec des
expositions et des spectacles à ne pas
manquer mais aussi du sport pour toute
la famille avec la 13ème édition de la
bio castor mais tout de suite place à
notre première invités venus nous parler
d'un salon qui ravira les fins gourmets
ce week end
le samedi 15 et le dimanche 16 novembre
amour passé la deuxième édition du salon
des vins saveurs et des couleurs pour en
parler avec nous en plateau à
l'intelligence bonjour région vous êtes
le président du lions club de maurepas
50 ans et vit le doyen ou quelles
initiatives de ce salon alors est ce que
vous nous expliquer un peu ce succès ce
qui sera proposé alors ce qui sera
proposé c'est un salon qui réunira des
viticulteurs qui réunira des producteurs
y compris des artisans d'où ces vins des
saveurs des produits gastronomiques qui
viendront de toutes les régions de
france et également au niveau des
couleurs ça peut intriguer ce terme de
couleurs ce sont les arts de la table
décoration florale de tout ce qui touche
au tour disons d'honneur de la table de
quoi ravir nos papiers dont il y aura
deux tours du vin du champagne du web
soit les atteignent aura tout à fait
qu'elle quel type de produit un peu
phare pouvait nous enfin il ya de si
vous voulez ce qu'on a souhaité c'est
par cette opération
je vous explique la qui répondent à
différents objectifs mais au niveau donc
des exposants c'est de faire la
promotion de producteurs d'artisans donc
de mettre en valeur le savoir-faire de
ses artisans et de ses producteurs
d'accord pour les questions pratiques
donc le samedi ça se passe de 11h à 21h
donc et le dimanche de 10 heures à 18
heures à la salle des fêtes je ne mords
pas au niveau la zone d'activités paris
ouest
alors les artisans viennent d'où non pas
uniquement ils viennent un peu de toute
la france justement de manière à pouvoir
présenter des produits je dirais avec
authenticité donc notamment au niveau
des viticulteurs
nous faisons pas appel à des négociants
mais à des producteurs eux mêmes je pars
faire de publicité spécifique pour tel
ou tel mais par exemple j'ai en tête à
l'instant un producteur jeune couple
haut niveau au champagne qui est un très
très beau produit est très compétitif
voilà c'est eux qui travaillent la terre
produisent et des god et vendent leurs
propres produits c'est un peu notre
objectif
les artisans alors nous avons j'allais
dire écumé un petit peu les différents
salons qui sont faits dans la région et
puis chacun ayant déjà des contacts ou
même déjà se servant auprès de certains
quand les produits sont bons eh bien on
les a de nous mêmes contacté on a fait
une démarche individuelle en les
sollicitant pour les faire venir
nous aurons au total 41 exposants
d'accord 41 et les deux jours seront là
alors il ya effectivement une tombola
qui est fait si vous voulez pour que
collègues nous collections un petit peu
de fond parce que je vais vous expliquer
donc il ya la promotion des différents
exposants des différents producteurs
différents artisans mais notre objectif
en tant que lyon ce club c'est de
pouvoir
collecter des fonds de manière après ce
que nous puissions aider à provisionner
notre compte qu'on appelle d'oeuvres
sociales c'est en effet donc le yoyo ce
cap qui finance tout cela est absolument
vous êtes 25 bénévoles à maurepas alors
sur maurepas voilà nous sommes au niveau
du club de maurepas
saint-quentin-en-yvelines doyen nous
sommes 25 hommes et femmes qui se
trouvent réunis dans ce club parce que
nous partageons un certain nombre de
valeurs une certaine éthique avec comme
je dirais mission est comme tâche et
comme ambition enfin on essaie de
satisfaire sa au mieux de respecter la
devise de notre notre club service c'est
le plus grand club service au monde le
lions club qui est de servir ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que par ses
actions nous collectons des fonds et
ensuite nous allons et des
différentes structures ou différentes
personnes dans des situations difficiles
déjà en difficulté ça peut être des donc
vous reversez des associations ce jeu
peut être différente voilà tout à fait
ce que nous on l'a fait pour vous donner
quelques exemples avec une association
mauricienne qui s'appelle lève toi et
marche
qui s'occupe de la réinsertion
de personnes je dirais ans en difficulté
ont sorti même de
prison
fleur de bitume
ce sont des étudiants que nous aidons
les différents frais qu'ils rencontrent
pour aller faire du soutien scolaire
auprès de jeunes dans des familles
défavorisées
nous envoyons en vacances des enfants
dont les familles ne pourrait pas les
envoyer sans le fait avec l'aide de la
municipalité on leur offre quinze jours
de vacances
lorsque avant de venir je faisais bon
préparer un petit dossier de presse très
franchement quand j'ai relu tous ce que
nous faisions j'ai même été moi-même
surprise un étonnant d'être sûr ce n'est
pas ce qu'on fait ça fait longtemps que
quand vous y êtes actif au
sema 27e année le foie la bon c'est
l'association très importante même au
niveau national et vous êtes quand même
28 mille bénévoles répartis sur toute la
france sont de le rappeler nous sommes
28 bénévoles répartis dans 1230 club si
vous voulez avoir le chiffre au niveau
mondial et bien nous sommes à peu près
un million trois cent mille
répartis dans quarante huit mille clubs
au monde
c'est le plus grand club service
mais déjà bon sur le plan local
nous sommes une équipe de 25 est très
actif avec des participations à des
opérations qui sont aussi bien
nationales internationales dans les
cotisations que nous versons une partie
est consacrée à l'international
avec deux axes je crois c'est ce qu'il
faut retenir au niveau du lion ce club
il y a deux axes directeurs un accès
humanitaire est un axe humaniste donc ça
va pour les grandes catastrophes
malheureusement internationale quand
c'est un site web son ami quand c'est un
tremblement de terre des catastrophes
des inondations une partie nos
cotisations servent à aider via une
fondation internationale au niveau
national chaque année le lions club au
niveau de tous les pays il y en a 200 9
dans le monde pays et zones
géographiques
il est voté une action phare pour
l'année par exemple c'est depuis déjà
deux ans cette action c'est enfance et
santé c'est une action en faveur de
toutes les mesures qui peuvent être
faites des traitements pour le cancer
chez l'enfant est aujourd'hui donc au
niveau de maurepas vous réfléchissez à
de futures actions là alors on réfléchit
effectivement aux futures actions un jeu
je souhaiterais que l'on puisse ce que
l'on fait déjà mais accentué notre je
dirais investissements au niveau de la
ville on a notamment tout à fait
récemment proposé à la municipalité
pour sensibiliser les automobilistes
par une campagne d'affichage
sur les emplacements réservés pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite c'est un
petit panneau qui est sympathique le
message est on ne peut plus gentil qui
est
si tu prends ma place prends mon
handicap bon ça c'est pour les inciter
disons respecter quand même la
signalisation donc ça c'est une petite
chose au niveau
il faudra aller plus loin c'est à dire
qu'on voudrait avoir une action phare et
on envisage le financement d'un véhicule
qui serait spécifiquement destinés à
faciliter le transport de personnes
âgées en difficulté sur la ville
ce week end des verts c'est donc ceux
qui viendront nous voir auront là
l'opportunité
de faire des achats de déguster de bons
produits de préparer leur rôle cadeaux
pour les fêtes de fin d'année et en même
temps et ça c'est important ils font une
bonne action parce que ça permettra
comme ça de pouvoir alimenter je dirais
non notre pièce pour nous avons social
c'est important donc je le rappelle donc
c'est tout tout le week end à maurepas à
la salle des fêtes donc de 11h à 21h le
samedi de 10h à 18h le dimanche est
l'occasion pourquoi pas aussi de faire
vos premières emplettes pour noël
merci à l'intelligence d'être revenue
sur notre plateau on passe maintenant
aux expositions et aux autres événements
culturels du week end
ce samedi 15 novembre derniers jours et
dernières occasions de découvrir
l'exposition consacrée à la grande
guerre à montigny le bretonneux elle se
déroule à la fois en mairie et dans les
locaux de l'union nationale des anciens
combattants catherine mulato et william
l
pas moins de 300 objets collectés
répertoriés et commenter la grande
guerre n'est pas venu dans les yvelines
mais des soldats sont partis au front et
ce sont ses souvenirs militaires comme
personnels qui seront exposées des armes
il y avait énormément et des armes rares
dont un fusil anglais des médailles
aussi parce qu'il ya des médailles aussi
bien étrangère que française
et aussi il ya des étriers seront les
choses pas très rares qui sont des
étriers de cavalerie dans nos
particularités de s'ouvrir pour pas que
le cavaliere est accrochée à la scène
parmi les armes présenter ce fusil
lourdes 4 kg 5 je suis dit là il était a
été mise en service en 1907 italie
enfield numéro un il a été fabriqué en
17 versions différentes
c'est un bon travail honnête c'est une
brique lung qui se dit ici
si le calibre 303
je fus il a été utilisé jusqu'en 1941
des pièces plus personnel sont également
proposés des lettres de poilus des
cartes postales des journaux de bord
écrit chaque jour pour mieux comprendre
l'enfer de la grande guerre il ya des
objets personnels oui il ya des petites
miniatures de plomb moi j'étais jeune
j'ai de mon de mon père qui était né en
1900 qui a fait les deux hier donc
j'essaie décoration ça c'est personnel
l'exposition a pu voir le jour grâce au
travail mené par le club des
collectionneurs des yvelines elle est
présentée au siège de l'ufc dans les
locaux de l'ancienne mairie une seconde
partie de l'exposition à elle visible à
l'hôtel de ville jusqu'au 15 novembre
la commune de montigny le bretonneux
fait partie des douze villes des
yvelines avoir obtenu la labellisation
délivré par l'office national des
anciens combattants
culture toujours donc avec cette soirée
des écrivains persécutés emprisonnés est
empêché pour la quatrième année
consécutive à l'occasion de la semaine
qui est dédié à ses auteurs la maison de
la poésie leur donne la parole une
soirée de témoignage de lecture ou
encore de musique avec à l'honneur cette
année les artistes et écrivains syriens
rendez vous dès 20h ce samedi à la
maison de la poésie il reste des places
pensez à réserver allez on passe du côté
de montigny de magny les hameaux pardon
ce samedi toujours l'estaminet propose
un spectacle jeune public tout en
lumière et en poèmes les enfants
pourront ainsi partir à la découverte de
la lune dès 11h il reste des places
également les réservations peuvent se
faire directement sur internet
c'est une activité un peu plus sportive
est accessible à toute la famille que
nous vous proposons à présent la bio
castor pour en parler avec nous en pâte
en plateau sandrine tesson bonjour merci
nous avoir rejoints alors vous êtes
l'organisatrice de cet évènement qu'est
ce qui va se passer qu'est ce qui va se
passer nous organisons donc demain
samedi et dimanche un week-end de course
d'orientation avec samedi une épreuve de
course en course d'orientation à vtt et
le dimanche une course d'orientation
pédestre d'accord avec à chaque fois
donc des circuits différents exactement
c'est ensemble voilà on propose aux
compétiteurs des circuits de longueurs
différentes et de technicité différente
chaque chaque participant choisit bien
son circuit en fonction de sa forme
physique et de son niveau d'orientation
pour quelques informations pratiques je
le précise tout de suite donc le samedi
pour la course vtt c'est à partir de
12h30 au départ de la ferme du manet à
montigny le bretonneux le dimanche par
contre cet abus en cours pour les
circuits pédestres uniquement à partir
de 10 heures les départs se font
derrière parking de la batterie près du
gymnase des droits de l'homme à
guyancourt cette fois ci alors quel est
l'objectif de cette course d'orientation
sur quoi les les participants seront ils
jugés ils seront jugés sur leurs
la rapidité avec laquelle ils vont
effectuer le parcours donc ils auront
une carte en leur possession sur
laquelle sera dessiné un parcours qu'il
faudra suivre donc dans l'ordre dans
l'ordre des numéros indiqués sur la
carte est le plus rapide et le plus
celui qui aura choisi les itinéraires
les plus adaptées
remportera remportera l'épreuve
parmi les excuses ne remportera
l'épreuve par rapport aux autres qui
auront peut-être choisi d itinéraire
différent par rapport à ce qui est
proposé et aux chemins différents
chemins qui peuvent être utilisées sur
sur la forêt c'est accessible à partir
de quel âge alors on a sur la course
pédestre du dimanche une un parcours
spécifiquement réservée aux enfants aux
jeunes enfants qui s'appelle laminée aux
castors un parcours de 5 km vraiment
adapté pour pour les enfants avec
notamment des
des balises un petit peu spectacle avec
des animaux à trouver ou à découvrir dès
découvrir des lots sur sur place les
enfants sont bien évidemment accompagnés
de leurs parents mais ça reste vraiment
un circuit qui est adapté pour les
jeunes enfants d'accord tous les
circuits sont chronométrés avec un
classement final
il ya deux circuits qui ne sont pas
chronométrée qui sont donc réservés aux
gens qui préfèrent aborder cette épreuve
de manière un petit peu plus tranquille
à loisir ainsi que la mini aux castors
dont on vient de parler qui n'est pas
chronométrer les enfants recevront un
cadeau à l'issue de la course sinon nous
avons effectivement d'autres circuit
chronométré ou des compétiteurs
chevronnés
vont s'affronter d'accord donc l aspect
compétition quand même bien presse qui
reste on l'a vu un petit peu sur les
images il vaut mieux quand même être
bien équipé pour il faut être un petit
peu équipée non seulement alors déjà en
vtt il faut voilà il faut déjà avoir un
vtt
adapté et un porte carte pour pouvoir
donc chose pas si on le voit sur les
images mais en tout cas pour avoir la
carte devant soi et paris
et ainsi pouvoir suivre l'itinéraire et
il faut une boussole également pour
pouvoir s'orienter en forêt et en
équipant un petit peu un petit peu
protect protect pardon protecteur je
vais y arriver puisqu'on est en forêt
les conditions sont pas toujours pas
toujours bonne il ya déjà mille inscrits
enfin un petit peu moins environ 2000
inscrits sur le week-end c'est pas mal
c'est oui plus que les années
précédentes je sais pas si j'ai encore
dit mais c'est comme la 13e édition
c'est la 13e édition de la course
pédestre l'affectif centrale là au vtt
du castor qu'on a qu'on a inclus dans le
week-end ce sera la cinquième édition
très bien là se déplacent il reste
quelques places sur quelques circuits il
faut nous contacter pour voir si on peut
effectivement répondre à certaines
demandes mais on a été obligé
effectivement de clôturer les
inscriptions puisqu'il ya quand même en
amont besoin d'éditer les cartes pour
les concurrents et on est obligé de le
faire quelques jours avant le début de
l'épreuve et c'est votre club de
guyancourt orientation soit 118 qui
organise cet événement alors comment ça
se passe la préparation d'un tel
événement sûr parce qu à pas mal de
repérage ça va quand même prendre du
temps c'est assez effectivement c'est
quasiment une année de préparation on a
déjà même commencé à réfléchir à
l'édition 2015 c'est une année de
préparation pour le traceur des circuits
qui doit donc effectuer tout un tout un
tas de repérages sur le terrain et c'est
aussi beaucoup de beaucoup de rendez
vous avec avec les mairies ou les
communes qui nous accueille donc lui en
cours cette année toute la logistique a
préparé vérifier toutes les
autorisations nécessaires pour pouvoir
organiser cette course avec la
préfecture avec le nf la relation avec
les partenaires qui prend aussi du temps
mais qui est importante parce que c'est
aussi grâce à eux qu'on arrive à
organiser ce genre de manifestation donc
c'est vraiment un travail de longue
haleine on a une équipe de bénévoles qui
nous aident tout au long de l'année et
on aura environ 70 bénévoles tout au
long du week-end qui vont qui vont nous
aider à faire de ce week-end une
réussite vous êtes un club très
important avec aujourd'hui 185 orient
tort comme on les appelle exactement
c'est exactement on est le plus grand
club de france actuellement et au sein
de ce club dont vous pratiquez la course
de notation ont toutes ses formes en vtt
et à pied mais aussi à skis tout à fait
c'est une discipline qui se développe
qui n'est pas très très médiatisé mais
qui se développe donc on peut
effectivement faire de l'orientation à
skis donc dans les stations de ski
généralement avec un équipement
adapté effectivement pour pour cette
pratique puisque en ski on a besoin
d'avoir ses deux mains pour tenir les
bâtons donc on a une importante carte
qui est fixé au niveau du torse de
manière à avoir l'itinéraire est la
carte devant les yeux pouvoir s'orienter
en ski de fond très bien et au sein de
votre club comment ça se passe et les en
dés inscrire toute l'année qui
s'entraîne pour les compétitions tout à
fait on est on a des licenciés soit là
les orienteurs ce licenciement ce
licencié au club et grâce aux bénévoles
encore on est en mesure d'organiser un
entraînement par semaine sauf en période
de vacances scolaires
où un certain nombre de licenciés du
club donc participent pour progresser
pour apprendre en technicité et puis
pour ensuite participer à la tout un tas
de deux compétitions en ile-de-france et
dans la france entière puisque il ya
quand même des championnats de france
qui se qui se déroulent un peu partout
en france en tout cas si l'expérience
vous tente ce week end n'hésitez pas on
vous l'a dit il reste quelques places
plus beaucoup mais il en reste je le
rappelle c'est ce samedi et dimanche à
montigny le bretonneux et à guyancourt
pour les inscriptions notez bien le
numéro qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran celui de notre invité sandrine
tesson merci d'être venu sur notre
plateau merci beaucoup on passe tout de
suite aux événements musicaux du week
end
tv fil 78 2 vous propose un grand rendez
vous ce week end le concert du groupe
écossais franz ferdinand à rock en seine
en 2013 sera diffusée sur votre chaîne
de diffusion la première ce samedi 15
novembre à 20h30 et la deuxième ce
dimanche 16 novembre à 17h tous la
diffuser dans votre émission
philharmonique
en musique toujours ce samedi 15
novembre c'est le tremplin rock the
choice à montigny le bretonneux
l'occasion de découvrir les artistes qui
montent cinq groupes de rock se
produiront sur scène et tenteront de
gagner le coeur du public et des
amoureux de la musique rendez vous dès
20 heures à la salle paul gauguin et
pour ceux qui préfèrent le classique
simon fâche vous propose son spectacle
appelé pianiste au logis un mélange de
piano de one man show mais aussi
d'humour simon fâche c'est tout faire
pour le voir sur scène rendez vous ce
samedi à 20h30 à la batterie de
guyancourt vous pouvez réserver vos
places directement sur le site de
kiosque place maintenant à l'actualité
cinéma
et tout de suite les sorties ciné de la
semaine et les avis des spectateurs au
micro d' elodie moi c'est un film qui
n'a strictement aucun intérêt il ne se
passe rien c'est un film vraiment pour
ados
c'est tout le film était vraiment très
intéressant c'est un film assez
comment dire c'est un film qui nous a
vraiment mis dans le feu de l'action dès
le début ce que j'ai mais en fait
c'était
comment les petits ont aussi réfléchir
c'est un bon film j'étais content ça
reprend la suite du premier du deuxième
le troisième est un peu décevant mais on
retrouve le côté horreur bien flippant
si je peux dire donc c
bon film espagnol as ce qui était
intéressant c'est que ça reprenait un
peu dans la lignée du 1 et du 2 donc
c'était mieux parce que le 3 ça donne un
peu burlesque et là on retrouve
l'ambiance du premier du deuxième j'ai
beaucoup aimé c'est assez stressante un
moment c'est assez angoissant c'est très
bien c'est super j'ai beaucoup aimé très
très bien l'ambiance est spéciale et si
vous parlez de films d'auteur et j'ai
trouvé ça formidable beaucoup aimé aussi
et c'est très bien joué
guillaume canet et ana girardot qui sont
très très vrai
c'est un super film d'atmosphère quand
même plaisante
et notre coup de coeur de la semaine
c'est celui de bertrand pigné
programmateur et animateur des yeux
d'elsa à sentir l'école le coup de coeur
des yeux d'elsa ce mois ci c'est chambre
ton bac d'abord de david andré le mois
de novembre c'est traditionnellement le
mois du film documentaire on propose
quatre films documentaires ce mois ci et
on finit avec ce grand film qui a été
préparé pour la télévision à l'origine
chante ton bac d'abord donc et qui a été
sorti au cinéma ensuite nous proposons à
partir du 26 novembre pour trois
semaines parce que c'est un film qui
nous a vraiment touché énormément
c'est un film qui raconte l'histoire
d'un groupe de jeunes gens de 17 ans
dans l'art dans l'année de leur back
comme le dit le titre et qui vont dans
une ville de bord de mer touchés par la
crise et voilà par la réalité du
quotidien sont pris dans cette grande
question que faire demain que faire dans
les études mais que faire de soi de sa
vie quels grands projets à voir et la
grande originalité ce film c'est que
plutôt que d'être un regard frontale sur
des gens et de demander à ce qu'il se
livre à la caméra le réalisateur a
préféré leur demandait d'écrire des
choses qu'il a lui-même ensuite
transformé en chansons et ses chansons
sont chantés à l'écran dans des moments
remis en scène très joliment d'ailleurs
par ces mêmes jeunes qui ont écrit ses
textes alors ça pourrait passer par être
pour une sorte de comédie musicale
de moyenne gamme et puis un nom c'est un
vrai beau film avec une vraie respect de
la chanson française de beaux textes de
très belles musiques et surtout une
plongée dans le quotidien de ces jeunes
gens et de leurs familles puisqu'on y
voient aussi leurs parents c'est un film
important pour nous parce que nous
recevrons également pour sa dernière
présentation du film le réalisateur
david andré qui a fait un peu le tour de
france avec le film et qui viendra nous
voir et discuter avec nous et avec vous
donc ça a lieu le 26 novembre à 20h30 et
j'espère vous y retrouver nombreux
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous souhaite un
excellent week end